ALEX KOMOROSKE: Hi.
So I'm Alex Komoroske.
MAX HEINRITZ: I'm
Max Heinritz.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: We're two
Product Managers on Chrome's
Open Web Platform team.
Now most of this session is
going to be just questions and
answers from you guys.
You'll see there's that Google
Moderator link up there.
You can leave questions on
there, or you can ask them
live, whichever you prefer.
But that's what we'll spend
most of our time on.
Before that, Max and I are going
to talk for a couple
minutes about Blink and the
progress we've made in the
past month.
So it's kind of crazy.
But it's only been a little
bit over a month since we
announced Blink.
And Blink, for those who don't
know, is a new rendering
engine originally based
on WebKit that
we're using in Chromium.
The mission statement of Blink
is to improve the open web
through technical innovation
and good citizenship.
So I'm going to talk about the
technical innovation par, and
Max will talk briefly about
the good citizenship part.
So when we made the decision
to create Blink, it was a
really hard one that we had
to come to terms with.
But it came down to,
fundamentally, that Chromium
used a different multiprocess
architecture from other
WebKit-based browsers.
And that increased complexity,
not just for the Chromium
team, but for everybody
who is using WebKit.
So we mentioned back when we
made the announcement that we
anticipated that we could remove
about 4.5 million lines
from the codebase.
And that was things like build
systems for other ports,
JavaScriptCore, because we use
V8, some of the WebKit2
porting layer, and a number
of other things.
But the progress we've
made since then has
really blowing our minds.
In fact, we've removed
now, I think, $8.8
million lines of code.
So that's just a really cool
stat, I think, that shows that
we've been able to streamline
this even
more than we expected.
That's 63% of the
repo, I think.
And it's also 191 megabytes
of code.
So less code is better for
developers, because it means
that people who are working on
Blink, they can check out the
codebase faster.
They can build faster.
And of course, less code is less
surface area for bugs.
And it hasn't just actually been
us that's been able to
clean up like this.
The WebKit project as well has
really been able to clean out
some stuff that was really
just there for Chromium.
So it's been really great
for both projects.
These are just really
easy stats to pull.
What actually really matters is
developer productivity and
how much stuff we can do to
improve the stability and
performance of Blink.
But what I'm most excited about,
actually, is not just
the performance or the
development and productivity
but some of the cool new
experiments that we've been
able to start that we couldn't
have done before.
So one of those is a project
called Oilpan.
And this is, just again, an
experiment into seeing if we
can move the DOM nodes into
a garbage collected heap.
So today, DOM nodes, they use
a reference counting system,
and it interacts in a very
complex way with the
JavaScript engine.
And so if this works, it could
really help make that much
simpler and much easier
to understand and less
error-prone.
Another cool one is called
Lazy Block Layout.
Again, a very early
experiment.
The idea is, what if we could
make very large but simple
layouts much, much
faster to do?
So if you're only using a
handful of features, why can't
we make that much,
much faster?
And if it works, this would
allow things like infinite
scrolling lists to be much
easier to accomplish on the
web platform.
So those are literally just two
totally random examples of
experiments that we've started
in the past month or so with
Blink that we're really
excited about.
There's a whole bunch
of other ones.
All of the stuff about these and
the other ones are on our
mailing list.
Cool.
MAX HEINRITZ: Thanks, Alex.
So Alex talked a lot about how
Blink enables technical
innovation.
But it's important to balance
that momentum with
interoperability.
We want the whole web to evolve,
not just Chrome.
That's where the second half
of our mission statement
comes, good citizenship.
I'm going to talk about a couple
of our initiatives in
this area and how they might
be relevant to you guys, as
web developers.
The first thing I want to point
out is that all of our
code is open source.
So you can go to our project
page, chromium.org/blink, to
download that.
I'll show a link at the end.
The next thing I want to talk
about is our transparent
Launch Review process.
Launch Review process is healthy
for projects in many
different ways.
For us, it's important for
external contributors to
understand how they can work
with our team to lend their
code in the codebase.
It's also important to build
consensus early on in the
development process and
avoid conflicts later.
And finally-- and this one is
really important for us--
we don't want to ship
proprietary features, and the
launch process helps
avoid doing that.
Basically, when we ship
something in Chrome on the web
platform, we want all browsers
to ship it, not just Chrome.
So the way this works in
practice is say you're a Blink
engineer and you want to a web
platform feature or somehow
change the behavior we expose
to web developers.
Before you start writing code,
we ask you to first send an
intent to implement email
to our public
mailing list, blink-dev.
This email follows a
template format.
We ask you to provide a link
to the specification, a
description of use cases and
motivation, and finally give
an overview of compatibility
risk.
And in that last section, what
we're looking for is, do other
browser vendors think this
feature is a good idea?
Is it making progress through
the standardization process?
And usually, there's some
discussion that follows about
whether this is something that
belongs in Blink or not.
Later, when the feature's ready
to ship, we ask them to
send another email, an intent
to ship email, which is
scrutinized a little
bit more carefully.
It's only been about a month or
so, but this launch process
seems to be working
pretty well.
We've had 40 of these
"Intent" threads.
And of those, we're proud to
say that a third have come
from non-Googlers.
We've had "Intent" threads come
from people like Intel,
Adobe, Opera, and, earlier
this week, Microsoft.
So pretty exciting stuff.
One thing I want to point out
before I move on is that this
process isn't designed to
prevent us from shipping
things only in Chrome.
It's designed to force us to
be very deliberate and
thoughtful if we ever
decide to do that.
So that's just something
to keep in mind.
Another thing I want to point
out is that everything I just
talked about is public.
You can participate and follow
along in our public mailing
list, blink-dev@chromium.org.
But at the same time, I
understand that not everyone
has the time to follow all of
the intricacies of browser
development.
And so there are a couple other
ways that you can stay
up to date on what we're working
on that don't involve
so much traffic.
So I'll talk about them and
order them on this slide from
most traffic at the top, which
is blink-dev, to the ones with
less noise at the bottom.
So in addition to blink-dev,
we have a cool site called
chromestatus.com, which I'll
show you guys now.
Ooh, the resolution isn't
very good right now.
Basically, this is a spreadsheet
where each row
corresponds to a feature that
we're currently working on or
recently shipped.
There's some logistical
information, like the
feature's name, who the owner
is, the bugs, its
implementation status
in Chromium.
And then over here, the
cells are colored.
And these columns correspond
to things that we think
reflect web citizenship, so for
example, progress through
standardization, the views of
other browser vendors, the
excitement from web
developers.
And our goal with this is
to have a nice visual
representation of how each
feature reflects our web
citizenship.
And then, as you scroll down,
you can kind of see the
project's overall citizenship,
just based on these colors.
So right now this is just an
iframed Google spreadsheet,
but we're hoping to make
progress here.
I'll point out how you can
actually subscribe to get
email notifications when
there's changes made.
Just go in here and enable
Notification Rules, and you
can get emails to
stay up to date.
I also want to point out that
we've gotten great community
help with this spreadsheet.
Is Masataka here from Japan?
Yeah.
Masataka has been an
enormous help.
And we actually haven't met in
person yet, so it would be
great if you could come
up after the talk.
But yeah.
It's really awesome to see
people coming together to help
build this set of information.
OK.
Back to the slides.
So those are two ways you can
stay up to date on features.
A third way is through our
Developer Relations team.
They have Google+ and Twitter
channels that you can follow.
And then finally, every time we
launch a new Chrome beta,
we publish a Chromium blog post
which describes all of
the web platform changes, and
that includes things like
deprecations, which might
be relevant to you guys.
So these are a couple ways that
you can stay up to date
on what's going on in Blink.
Again, you can get
this information
on our project page.
So the last thing I want to talk
about before we turn it
over to Q&A is web platform
feature adoption.
Google's in a pretty unique
place, in terms of
understanding how people
are using the web.
We want to make this information
available to other
people who might be
interested in it.
So what you're looking
at here is data from
Google Search Index.
Basically, what we did is we
ran a graph over all of the
pages that we have and
tried to look for new
HTML5 element tags.
And so this top line, for
example, is header.
And you can see that usage has
increased from something like
7% of web pages a couple months
ago to near 9% now.
So this graph is just kind
of useful information.
But we're trying to get the
similar data for CSS and for
JavaScript APIs.
And this could be useful in a
couple ways that I'll just
list out now.
One is say you're a browser
engineer, and you're trying to
optimize CSS.
It would be pretty useful to
have a list of all of the CSS
properties and their frequency
across the web so that you can
know which code pass would be
most efficient to optimize.
Another example is, say you're
a specification editor, and
you want to know if you can make
breaking changes to the
spec without breaking the web.
This would help you feel
comfortable doing that.
For web developers, it's just
interesting to see what's
reaching the mainstream
and what they can
use in their websites.
And finally, this is important
for us as the Blink team, is
that we can get information
on when we can responsibly
deprecate features.
And so a good example of this
is with prefixed versus
unprefixed features.
Oftentimes, when we release
an unprefixed version of a
feature, we can't remove support
for the prefixed
version because the
web would break.
And so we're stuck with this old
code path for the prefixed
version when we really don't
need it any more, because we
have the unprefixed version.
And so we can use this system to
track not only adoption of
new features, but also decline
of old features and knowing we
can feel comfortable
removing them.
So this is the project page
I was referencing,
chromium.org/blink.
Go there.
There's a bunch of
information.
And then, just to summarize real
quick, Alex talked a lot
about how Blink enables
technical
innovation on the web.
And I talked about how it's
important to stay good
citizens and make sure that
innovation goes both ways,
both from the community
to Blink and from
Blink to the community.
So now we have time for some
Q&A. And I'm going to invite
some people from the team up.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So Darin,
Eric, and Paul, you
want to come up?
MAX HEINRITZ: Yeah.
So we have a Google Moderator.
And we're taking questions
from the audience, too.
So do you guys want
to introduce
yourselves real quick?
DARIN FISHER: Sure.
PAUL IRISH: My name
is Paul Irish.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Chrome.
My name's Eric Seidel.
I work on Blink.
DARIN FISHER: Hi.
My name's Darin Fisher.
I'm an engineering
lead on Chrome.
MAX HEINRITZ: OK.
So you guys are welcome to come
up to the microphones if
you have any questions.
Otherwise, we'll just run
through the Dory.
OK.
I'll start with an audience
question.
AUDIENCE: One thing I want to
know, please, when Blink is
coming to Android WebView.
Right now WebView classic is
there, and there's support
for, if you install
Chrome, then the
view defaults to Chrome.
But when will Blink
will become a
default WebView on Android?
DARIN FISHER: So actually, if
you follow the chromium.org
project, you can see that
there's an Android WebView
project being built there.
You can actually check out the
code and try it yourself.
What I can say is that it's
under development.
We're very interested, of
course, in bringing the best
of the Chromium engine, Blink
included, to Android.
And that includes not only
Chrome on Android but also the
WebView implementation.
AUDIENCE: Right now the Coda,
which is in Android underscore
WebView, there's a TestShell
there, which you can build.
I guess it doesn't work.
Or at least it's kind of
partly implemented.
Right?
ERIC SEIDEL: So in terms of
developing Blink on Android,
generally we actually
use Content Shell.
That's sort of a new way.
TestShell was the old way.
And you're right.
Both of them are under a lot
of flux right now after the
Blink transition.
And I think you'll see
those stabilize
in the coming months.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is about
vendor prefixes.
So Blink won't be having them,
and instead opting for kind of
like a dev gate for experimental
features.
Now some prefixed CSS properties
are older than
Chrome itself and are still
prefixed in Chrome.
However, I've been deploying
them in apps
for many years now.
So my worry with this new policy
is that the only saving
grace of vendor prefixes will
be lost, that I won't get to
push new web platform features
to users in a
near-term time frame.
So my question is, how
aggressively is the Chrome
team going to be locking away
these experimental features
behind this dev wall?
ERIC SEIDEL: So I'll take the
first part of that question.
To start with, vendor prefixes,
as probably most of
you know, are when it
says WebKit-fu as a
property or as a value.
And we in Blink are trying
to avoid that.
We don't want to introduce
yet another Blink-fu.
Vendor prefixes are just like
any other API that we've
shipped, and we don't
want to break.
So we have been measuring, like
max has said, to make
sure that we don't break
your website as we
work to remove these.
And most of that policy is about
forward looking, that we
don't want to add new ones.
And we'll be trying to remove
the existing ones as we find
that we can, as their
usage falls off.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So I think a
second part of your question
as well is this concern that the
prefixing system used to
allow new emerging web standards
or features to be
deployed before they were
fully standardized.
And that allows you to play with
all these great goodies.
The problem is that prefixing
was supposed to be a warning
to developers of don't
rely on this.
It might go away at any time.
But it's just like any other
API, where people start using
it, and then if you turn
it off, the web breaks.
And so with this process, it's
definitely something where we
have to push a little bit harder
and talk with people
like Mozilla, for example, the
guy behind you in line there,
to talk about features.
And we think this is
a great feature.
What are your plans?
If Mozilla says, yeah, we
love this too, awesome.
If there's a spec, awesome.
But it definitely will require
us to push a little bit harder
to make sure that other browser
vendors are interested
in the same things that we're
interested in turning on.
AUDIENCE: Do you think that
the pace of progress might
slow down, as a result?
DARIN FISHER: I think that's
a great question.
I think that we're very
fortunate that we are not
alone in having a six-week
release cycle.
If you look at Mozilla, they
also have an accelerated
release cycle, and they also
have a desire not to ship
vendor prefix features.
And since they also have a
desire to improve the web
platform, it seems like
we have this wonderful
opportunity to capitalize on
this shared ambition to
improve the platform and not
just litter it with a bunch of
Moz dash and WebKit dash or
Blink dash, to actually do the
right thing and move quickly.
And so, actually, in many ways I
feel like we can actually do
a better job than we
could in the past.
Because in the past,
what did we do?
We added something, and then
when another vendor came
along, they want to do it
a little differently.
And then we had another
way to do it.
And you end up with multiple
different ways of doing the
same thing.
For example, we had three
different ways in CSS of
expressing gradient.
That's not fun.
And so, it seems really
promising now that, like I
said, with Mozilla on the
six-week release cycle and
Chrome on a six-week release
cycle that we could be able to
do the right thing
and quicker.
PAUL IRISH: I guess I'll also
add that browser vendors and
sanders groups have felt a
greater urgency to get things
done and get it shipped and
available to users recently.
The CSS working group, in
particular, has identified
that getting things to Candidate
Rec, which is the
point at which, basically, there
is multi-vendor interest
in implementations out there,
that that is a key target to
get done within a year.
And so, sanders groups really
want to make sure that things
are accelerated and still
everyone had a chance and
developers have a chance
to get feedback.
At the same time, browser
vendors don't want a bunch of
features to be locked behind
this one flag for years.
We want to make sure that
they ship out too.
Now I think this model's really
good, because we're not
able to ship a feature that just
kind of sits out there in
prefix land forever.
It's not shipped.
And so we want it to get out
there, and we're going to do
the legwork to make sure that it
reaches the standardization
goals so that it can actually
get to users.
But I expect that you're going
to see things quick.
You're going to have it
available for your users as
soon as we can make it happen.
AUDIENCE: That all
sounds fantastic.
Thanks a lot, guys.
MAX HEINRITZ: Let's do one
question from the Dory.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's
all right.
MAX HEINRITZ: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to know
what the expected user
flow was for enabling
these features.
Is there a way that we can kind
of prompt users and say,
hey, I'm going to use this
special feature, say, on a
Chrome experiment site and
I get a little bit easier
interaction, so they don't have
to go to Chrome Flags and
enable it deeper?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So that's
actually intentional.
AUDIENCE: I know.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: About flags
is a little bit
scary for our end users.
And we know that.
And that's one of the reasons
that's the place you
go in to flip it.
Otherwise, you convince all
your users, all the users
everywhere, to flip their
experimental flags on, and now
that's de facto.
And so we are definitely trying
to figure out how to
balance this.
So you want people to be able
to use the features, to use
them in real life websites
and give feedback to
standardization to other
browser vendors.
But you also don't want to
get them stuck with a bad
implementation that
you can't change.
AUDIENCE: No.
I definitely understand that.
With prefixes, it was a
transparent process.
With the notification, then
it's a user op-in.
And major websites aren't
going to ask the user to
enable 100 different
experimental things.
But I'm afraid that it might
change the way that
experimentations with the new
features are exposed.
If it's only developers that are
going in an changing those
flags, then you're not going
to get as much community
interest from the
non-developers.
DARIN FISHER: Here's one
way to look at it.
Before Blink, it was a little
bit more difficult for us to
experiment with web
platform features.
And now we have the ability to
more easily put things in
behind a flag.
And that allows us to not only
get an implementation
experience, but it also
allows web developers
to try it more easily.
Previously, if we wanted to do
that kind of thing, often it
meant doing a branch of Chromium
and then trying to
get somebody to download
that custom build.
It was a lot harder to get the
feedback that we need from web
developers.
So really, hopefully this
accelerates the feedback
process and improves--
That's a big part of the
standardization process is
getting web developers to chime
in and give their input.
And being able to actually try
out an implementation is key
to that, but also to be able
to try without making that
long-term commitment that
we do have when
we release a feature.
And as, I think, others on the
panel have said, when we ship
something with a vendor prefix,
it was just as much of
a commitment to the web
community as an API that was
unprefixed.
It doesn't really matter
that it's in
some standard somewhere.
If we put it there and people
start depending on it, we're
stuck with it.
It's part of the platform,
like it or not.
And so we just wanted to sort of
turn that around and focus
on trying to do the right
thing and not creating
more of this mess.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Flexbox is a pretty good
example of that.
MAX HEINRITZ: OK.
Let's do one question from the
Moderator, and then we'll take
another audience question.
So the question is, "Chrome on
Windows has had issues with
webfont rendering for a
long time now, even
with Google Web Fonts.
Is solving these issues
a priority on Blink?".
DARIN FISHER: Absolutely.
This was specifically asking
about fonts on Windows?
Yeah.
Actually, we have work underway
to add support for
subpixel positioning of
fonts on Windows.
We have that enabled
on other platforms.
The challenge on Windows is just
that the GDI, the font
rendering system that
we have been using,
doesn't support it.
And we're working to move
to DirectWrite.
The challenge with DirectWrite
is our sandbox architecture
kind of works against the
way DirectWrite works.
However, there is a solution
to that, and it's in
development now.
And so it should be available
behind a flag shortly, if not
in a canary shortly after.
MAX HEINRITZ: Cool.
Audience question.
Let's go here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
In building on what you talked
about, about getting the new
APIs out quicker in a year, I'm
obviously familiar with
that and have worked with you
guys on several things.
In the future, a few years now,
lots more APIs will be in
the web platform.
And Paul, you talked
about it as the
platform and "The Platform".
I guess my question is, with
Boot to Gecko, we want to
start a conversation, and a
conversation with everyone.
And have you guys felt
internally those urges of,
hey, what about when we land
these powerful features that
give us parity with things
people are able to do on apps
on the phone and stuff
like that and
these native languages?
Have you talked about what
comes next outside of the
browser or the web being a
foundation for a device like a
phone or anything like that?
DARIN FISHER: It sounds like, as
you probably know, we have
the Chrome packaged
app system.
And there's a lot of overlap
there with Boot to Gecki.
I don't know if you were here
for the previous talk.
Eric answered a similar question
about Sys Apps
Working Group and
standardization of these sort
of web platform extensions that
are designed to allow you
to build apps that live in
that native apps style
sandbox, as opposed to drive
by web style sandbox.
And I think it's absolutely a
really rich area to explore
collaboration and finding ways
to standardize and agree on
what these APIs look like.
It's sort of the early days for
some of these platforms.
And I know that our team has
been talking with folks at
Mozilla and trying to find
commonalities, trying to learn
more about how each other's
thinking about it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I just had to ask after seeing
the giant Chrome Android.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: We think
the web is pretty cool.
If that wasn't clear.
MAX HEINRITZ: Let's do a live
question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I'm a bit curious about
resources on the Blink team.
So now that you started out up
at the Blink project, the
upper guys have joined too, what
does this mean in terms
of resources on the team?
Are you scaling up the team
internally to invest more
resources into Blink and the
rendering engine, or are you
going to continue at
the same pace?
What does it mean that Opera
has joined the project?
ERIC SEIDEL: So I think the
bigger wins have come less
from us hiring more people--
because, as far as I know, I
haven't seen a lot of new
people being hired--
and more just there's a certain
budget of complexity
for our project.
There's only so many
things you can do.
And when we were in WebKit, we
had to do 101 things that we
just didn't need to do.
And now we just got rid of those
101 things, and so now
we can take that same complexity
budget and spend it
on much more interesting
features for you guys, on
getting features to you faster,
on doing interesting
things like runtime flags.
And so I don't see our team size
changing very quickly.
These guys would know better
than I. But we suddenly have a
whole lot more mind share
to spread around.
DARIN FISHER: I would just add
that we love to grow the team
with talented engineers who are
interested in improving
the web platform.
MAX HEINRITZ: OK.
Another live question.
AUDIENCE: So my question
involves the
divergence from WebKit.
Right now, when we're building
websites, you
check it against IE.
You check it against
a WebKit browser.
You should test events against
both Chrome and Safari.
But for the most part, WebKit
is WebKit, and all WebKit
browsers render things pretty
much the same way.
Moving forward, as Chrome and
Blink adds features, like the
Web MIDI API that WebKit is
opposed to, I don't want to
say fragmentation, but how can
we move forward from this
world we're in now, where we
have to check against all
these different rendering
engines, if we keep adding
features to some rendering
engines that other ones just
do not want to do at all?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So to be clear
on that specific example, Max
was talking earlier about our
intent to implement versus
intent to ship.
So it's very different.
So the intent to ship is, yes,
we are ready to commit to this
forever, basically.
Intent to implement is, yeah, we
think this is interesting.
We think that this could
be something we
would want to ship.
It's worthwhile to get the
experience of implementing it,
getting it in the hands of
developers behind a flag and
playing around with it.
So Web MIDI has had its intent
to implement on blink-dev.
And it looks interesting.
We're a little bit concerned
about some of the issues that
you just talked about.
And before we'd ever ship it,
by default we'd have to very
carefully weigh those
kinds of things.
So throughout all of this,
we want to minimize that
compatibility risk.
Because every time that there's
a feature that you
could target in one browser
that you can't target in
others, that hurts compatibility
a little bit.
And so we're very aware of that,
and we think about it
basically throughout all
these decisions.
It's one of the primary
things in our heads.
One other area that we can help
address this, by the way,
is testing.
So to some extent, one of the
reasons that you have to do a
lot of testing is because
browsers implement different
standards slightly differently,
or maybe the
standard wasn't clear
on something or was
ambiguous in some area.
But actually, having better
testing can help the different
browser vendors just make
sure they work the same.
And if you find something
where they both work
differently but they both are
within the terms of the spec,
well, the spec has a bug.
Fix that bug in the spec, and
figure out what the right
behavior is.
And so we're looking into
working with a bunch of other
folks to improve coverage of
testing that many of the
different browser
vendors can run.
I think that's a really great
long-term solution to this
kind of problem.
PAUL IRISH: And I guess the
other part of this is to your
question where there's
not the same feature
parity across browsers.
This has kind of been the
case for a while.
And even if we do have all
browsers shipping the same
features, there's going
to be a different
release schedule at least.
So I think feature detection
is the right
way to handle this.
There's going to be an uneven
surface if you're developing
against edge of the web where
there are features present in
some cases and not
in other places.
In some cases, the experience
can degrade.
You don't need that feature
to deliver the experience.
And that's awesome when
you could do that.
In other cases, you can
find a polyfill.
You can find some other
way to handle it.
But I guess that's kind of the
way to deal with that.
DARIN FISHER: Yeah.
I was just going to add that
when we forked WebKit to
create the Blink Project, when
it comes to new features like,
say, something like Web MIDI,
it's not that if we had stayed
on WebKit there was any
promise that Apple was
actually going to
ship Web MIDI.
We had developed many features
for WebKit that
Apple had yet to ship.
And so really we sort of feel
like the better path is, if we
care about a feature, we want
to get it out there and get
developers using it.
And it's really through that
excitement and energy around
the feature and the cool things
that people build with
it, that's what will convince
the other browsers to come
along, if they're not
already convinced.
So there's always this sort of
tug and pull and push and pull
kind of a dynamic.
At any rate, Blink is largely
about allowing us to more
efficiently move the web
platform forward.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you very much.
MAX HEINRITZ: Cool.
Thanks for the question.
OK.
Let's do one question
from the Moderator.
"What change, feature, or
improvement are you personally
was excited about the
possibility of implementing in
Blink?"
PAUL IRISH: One of the ones
that I'm psyched about--
I think, Eric, you might have
mentioned this one.
I don't think it's under
development.
You can tell me--
multi-threaded style
recalc and layout.
It's going to be awesome.
I'll tell you a little
bit of background.
So a lot of times you'll open
up the Chrome Dev Tools,
you'll do a Timeline, and you'll
be identifying what
your bottleneck is.
And in a lot of cases, there's a
lot of time spent in layout,
sometimes in style recalc,
depending on how much heavy
DOM manipulation you're doing.
And pretty much it's
single-threaded, going from
style recalc out from seeing
something on the screen.
And it can slow down your app.
So being able to basically take
some of these operations
and throw them to a separate
thread or a separate core, I'm
totally jazzed about
those experiments.
ERIC SEIDEL: He stole
my answer.
But I'm actually also really
excited about the Oilpan stuff
that you saw mentioned.
And that's not something I'm
personally working on.
I'm working more on the
rendering side of things,
making things really fast
for your website.
But Oilpan gives all sorts
of potential performance
benefits, all sorts of potential
memory benefits,
potential security benefits.
And it's kind of way out
there, from a feature.
But us being our own entity,
having our own experimental
branches, being able to do sort
of thing iteratively and
quickly is really
exciting to me.
DARIN FISHER: Yeah.
I totally agree.
I love both of those
experiments.
And I was just a little bit
surprised that you didn't
mention out a process iframes
on the slide, Alex.
That, to me, is one
of my most--
One of the dreams I've always
had for Chrome's multiprocess
architecture that it could not
just sandbox tabs but actually
sandbox origins.
And to me, it's just
really exciting.
So the idea of turning Blink
into more of a frame server,
if you will, like in the iframe
sense, and allowing us
to isolate origins to their own
processes, I think it's
just going to be fabulous,
especially in this Cloud
world, this world where most of
your data's in the Cloud.
The sandbox that we have in
Chrome is fabulous at allowing
users to be protected against
malicious web content that
might try to exploit
a bug to persist
malware on your computer.
It's great at that, protecting
against that.
But a lot of the viable data
that users have is right there
in the Cloud.
And our sandbox doesn't
do anything to help
protect that data.
But if we were able to isolate
origins into our own
processes, then, man, that would
be a huge step forward
for web security.
PAUL IRISH: I'm going
to do another one.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: You
can have mine.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
Lazy Block Layouts.
So it came up on the slide.
But I think so far we haven't
had a great explanation.
So stop me if I screw this up.
But let's say you have
a list view.
You have this view, especially
on mobile device.
You'll have a bunch of items.
And what you want your user to
do is be able to basically
fling it with their thumb and
it still respond great.
It's challenging.
There's been all these hacks to
make this work fantastic on
the web platform.
And Lazy Block Layout is
targeting this use case of I
got a lot items, I want to
fling it and it to be
responsive and awesome.
You can read about the proposal
on blink-dev, but
it's targeting something that
developers are dealing with a
lot and something baking into a
platform solution for that.
MAX HEINRITZ: Do you
have something?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I'll just to
say, it's not particular to
Blink, I guess-- oh, yeah--
is just web components.
If you've seen in past years,
I'm talking about
those again, again.
And we're going to have another
session tomorrow to
talk about it.
But I think web components is
an amazing set of emerging
standards that are really going
to change how people
write web apps.
MAX HEINRITZ: Another thing
we're working on is web
animations.
And this is a unified animation
model for the web.
And it's unclear how the WebKit
community would have
responded to this.
But it's something that Blink
gives us the ability to do on
our own, because we think
it's a good idea.
And so this will make animations
much faster.
And the cool stuff you saw with
Maps and Google+, users
are really looking for a rich
interactive experience.
And we need to provide that
in a performant way.
And web animations will
make that possible.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's, again,
another emerging spec that's
being worked on with
folks from Adobe
and Mozilla and others.
MAX HEINRITZ: Right.
OK.
Anything else?
Cool.
Let's do a live question.
AUDIENCE: So on deprecating
features, you guys use a
counter to measure
stats on the web.
And I'm wondering what
the usage stats
of the WebView apps.
Because the code used for
WebView apps tends to more
depend on WebKit prefix or an
Apple-specific properties methods.
So the usage stats tend
to be different from
the ones on the web.
Do you guys plan for
introducing a
use counter for WebView?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: One thing I
want to point out too is
there's lots of different
methods of trying
to figure this out.
And not one of them
is perfect.
And so the hope is that by doing
multiple methods you can
get something that an aggregate
is pretty good.
So if you're looking just at
something in the web index,
you're only going to see that
it was passed down from the
server originally.
And if you are running either
lots of other approaches and
techniques to get this
information, all of them have
some drawbacks.
That's a great one about
WebViews using slightly
different APIs in
different ways.
That's a great point.
DARIN FISHER: Yeah.
To answer your question about
use counter and WebView, I'm
not actually sure if we have
a solution for that.
It would be fabulous
to be able to get
the underlying data.
What we have in Chrome is a
histogram system that allows
us to collect usage stats
for users who opt in.
So when they download Chrome,
they check a box and say,
yeah, I'd happily allow you to
collect anonymous stats to
help make Chrome run better.
And that's the kind of system
that allows us to record
actual usage of features and
take advantage of that to try
to learn what's not actually
being used.
It's certainly not capturing
things like WebView apps,
because those apps don't prompt
their users to opt them
into that system.
There might be opportunities
to leverage into Chrome Dev
Channel, Chrome Beta Channel or
if there's ever a canary on
Android for that sort
of thing, but we
don't have that yet.
It is a challenge.
We also, with Chrome Apps and
the Chrome Store, we have the
ability to crawl that data
and find usage of
web platform features.
And we have used that in the
past to find things that would
be unfortunate to remove.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And ultimately,
if we mess up, the
hope is that when it's in Dev
Channel or Beta Channel,
someone will say, ooh, you just
broke all these lights.
And whoops.
And we'll relay it back.
MAX HEINRITZ: Nice.
Thanks.
OK.
Let's do another slide
from the Moderator.
Let's hear another question
from Moderator.
The question is, "There are
various inconsistencies in the
security policy enforcements
between Firefox and Chrome,
like with cross-domain fonts
and XHR on local files.
Will you be working together
to be more consistent?"
ERIC SEIDEL: Yes.
DARIN FISHER: Next question.
ERIC SEIDEL: I should also
note that before this
presentation, I emailed
Pamela.
And I will get her bugs,
and I will make sure
that we work on them.
DARIN FISHER: Cool.
MAX HEINRITZ: All right.
Let's do a live question.
Do you know which
of you is first?
OK.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Regarding the better
integration between DOM
elements in JavaScript, what
kind of performance
improvements can we expect,
especially with elements that
are pretty complex,
such as Canvas?
And what would be the
timeline there?
DARIN FISHER: Were you referring
to the Oilpan
project that we were talking
about with--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DARIN FISHER: --memory
management?
AUDIENCE: I think I read
something about exposing a
thinner layer around DOM
elements to JavaScript.
And all the calls into those
elements would be faster.
And I guess that would
have improvements for
objects like Canvas.
ERIC SEIDEL: So Canvas is
drawing to the screen or
drawing to a buffer.
And the vast majority of that
time is all spent actually
blitting the pixels and
turning them red
and blue and stuff.
So the stuff where you were
referring to about making the
DOM be able to talk to
JavaScript faster, that all
effects more things like when
you're traversing your whole
document or you're doing
a really tight loop and
constantly calling
some DOM API.
Talking to Canvas, if we have
the performance bugs there,
and I'm sure we do, those are
more things that we would talk
to our graphics team and help
make our blurs faster and our
fills faster and those
sorts of things.
And we want to fix those too.
So we'd love to know
about them.
MAX HEINRITZ: OK.
Audience question.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I just had a quick question
about the Blink Project.
How do you go from an
implemented feature to
shipping that feature,
especially if
you're not part of Google?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So the
intention, it's
all done via email.
There might be additional
meetings to review it, if it
needs more talking
back and forth.
And of course, in that case,
whoever's implementing it
would be invited to those
meetings to video conference.
And our goal is that people,
even non-Googlers, can be full
peers in this project.
And we take that
very seriously.
DARIN FISHER: I believe there's
been some intent to
ships from folks outside
of Google.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yeah.
I'm pretty sure that's true.
MAX HEINRITZ: Yeah.
I'm not sure about the intent to
ships, but we've definitely
had intent to implements.
Like I said, over a third have
come from non-Googlers.
So we try to make everything
really well documented,
because we understand that this
is an important thing for
an open source project.
So our project page is
chromium.org/blink.
And we explain everything
on there.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: We keep it up
to date as we're learning.
Because we're only a month or
so into this, and so we're
trying to figure out what's
the best way to balance a
minimum of process so you don't
have to have all kinds
of crazy overhead but also be
transparent, easy to follow,
and allow external contributors
to be peers in
the process and all that
kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MAX HEINRITZ: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Second question, how do you
become a committer?
Is it just like WebKit?
Or is it slightly different?
ERIC SEIDEL: It's just like
WebKit, maybe even easier.
There's a Chromium Committers
Policy.
It's like 10 commits,
sometimes sooner.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
MAX HEINRITZ: I think that's
all the time we have.
I Like I said, feel free to join
us on our mailing list,
blink-dev@chromium or go to
our project page for more
information.
And we'll hang out for a couple
minutes after, if you
have other questions.
Thanks, guys.